***
Okay, was drehen wir heute?
Tor, Tor, Tor, Tor!
Mit "Love and Thunder"
kommt nicht nur Thor in die Kinos.
Endlich ist auch Mjölnir mit dabei.
You're back.
Der Hammer!
Den Hammer hat diesmal
seine Ex in der Hand.
Jane Foster.
Das ist schon die 6. Person,
die den Hammer anheben kann.
Das macht mich neidisch.
Denn ich will das auch.
Vielleicht muss man auch nicht würdig
sein, um den Hammer anzuheben.
Vielleicht reichen schon
Technik und Physik dafür aus.
Wie das funktionieren könnte,
zeigen wir euch jetzt.
Hallo, Jack Pop hier.
Um Mjölnir anheben zu können,
müssen wir uns den Hammer anschauen.
Er wurde von Odin, dem König
von Asgard, in Auftrag gegeben.
Aber gemacht wurde er von Zwergen.
Das Material nahmen sie von Sternen.
Damit haben sie Mjölnir geschmiedet.
Mjölnir besteht aus Uru,
einem unzerstörbaren Metall.
Das existiert bei Marvel
seit Beginn des Universums.
Wenn es ums Anheben geht,
müssen wir nach der Masse fragen.
Darüber wird in den Foren
hitzig debattiert.
Die Rede ist von 42 Pounds,
also ca. 19 kg.
Aber die Masse ist unwichtig,
denn es hängt nicht an der Masse.
Denn es ist ganz egal,
wie stark jemand ist.
Der Hammer wurde von Odin verzaubert.
Anheben kann ihn nur, wer würdig ist.
Wie wäre das in der realen Welt.
Wer dürfte ihn anheben?
Kann man hier auch tricksen?
Das klären wir jetzt mit Niklas,
einem Wissenschaftsjournalisten.
Er erklärt auf seinem Account
komplexe Fragen in 60 Sekunden.
Wenn er eine Superkraft hätte,
würde er mit Tieren sprechen.
Hallo, Niklas,
- Hi.
Wie können wir das aus dem Film
in echt nachmachen?
Wir haben einen Hammer.
Aber nicht jeder kann ihn heben.
*Schrei*
Wie wäre der Workaround?
- Da gibt es etwas Cooles.
Im Film ist die Technik in Asgard
enorm fortgeschritten.
Das wirkt auf uns wie Magie.
You Ansgards call it magic.
And you call it science.
But I come from a place,
where it is the same thing.
Auch unsere Technik heute wäre
vor 100 Jahren wie Magie gewesen.
Z.B. Nanotechnologie.
Die könnte z.B. erkennen, dass es
Thor ist, der den Hammer heben will.
*Sie reden englisch.*
Das ist naheliegend von Toni,
Thors Fingerabdruck zu klauen.
Aber so einfach
ist es natürlich nicht.
Wir sehen auch andere Personen,
die das draufhaben.
Der Hammer hat also eher so etwas
wie einen Personen-Detektor.
Da gibt es schon verrückte Methoden.
Neben der Gesichtserkennung im Handy.
Es gibt z.B. die Möglichkeit,
Personen am Gang zu erkennen.
Aber auch
am Zungen- oder Gesäßabdruck.
Oh, that's not a question.
Ich habe gelesen,dass das US-Militär
Leute am Herzschlag erkennen kann.
Das läuft über einen Infrarotlaser.
Der nimmt minimale Veränderungen
auf Oberflächen wahr.
Denn unser Herzschlag ist
wie der Fingerabdruck einzigartig.
So identifiziert man Leute.
Das geht nicht allein
mit dem Finger oder Gesicht.
Das ist dann so, wie es ist.
Das kann man noch mit einer Art
Lügendetektor verbinden.
So kann man herausfinden,
wer würdig ist.
Einer fasst den Hammer an,
der Laser wird aktiviert.
Und über den Herzschlag checkt man,
ob er würdig ist oder nicht.
Das wäre eine Variante.
Gehen wir also von dieser Technologie
einmal aus.
Was müsste noch verbaut sein, damit
Unwürdige ihn nicht anheben können?
Voraussetzung müsste sein, dass der
Hammer die Schwerkraft ändern kann.
So erklärt das zumindest
James Kakalios.
D.h., das Uru-Metall müsste also
das Graviton beeinflussen können.
Diese Erklärung übernahm der
Marvelautor gleich mit in den Comic.
Diese Idee ist jetzt Teil
des Universums.
Das wäre echte Science Fiction.
In der Physik nimmt man an,
dass Graviton Elementarteile sind.
Die übertragen Schwerkraft.
So wie Photonen elektromagnet. Kraft,
also Licht, übertragen.
So nimmt man hier an, dass Graviton
Dinge fallen lassen kann.
Wenn ihr das zu Hause nachmachen
wollt, haben wir hier ein Experiment.
Ihr müsst nur einen Apfel nehmen,
um zu sehen, wie Graviton wirkt.
What the word I'm looking for?
Stupid?
- So stupid.
Schwerkraft wirkt immer
zwischen 2 Körpern.
Zwischen mir und der Erde,
zwischen dir und mir.
Alle Kräfte in der Physik
haben solche Übertragungsteilchen.
Deshalb wird die Idee erzeugt,
dass es Millionen Gravitone gibt.
Die würden dann diese Kraft
übertragen.
Ich rede im Konjunktiv, weil man sie
bisher noch nicht nachgewiesen hat.
Im Gegensatz
zu den anderen Elementarteilchen.
Das liegt daran, dass die Schwerkraft
von allen Kräften die schwächste ist.
Das kommt uns nicht so vor, sieht man
aber, wenn wir Dinge anheben.
Selbst Fliegen schaffen es,
an der Decke hängen zu bleiben.
Und das, obwohl die gesamte Masse
der Erde an ihr zieht.
Es gibt keine präzisen Messgeräte,
um die Gravitonen nachzuweisen.
Was aber nachgewiesen wurde,
sind Gravitationswellen.
2016 war das eine Sensation,
weil sie schwer nachzuweisen sind.
Dazu braucht man lange Tunnel,
um die Raum-Abweichung zu messen.
Die Gravitationswellen,
die man 2016 entdeckte,
haben die 1/1000tel des Durchmessers
eines Atomkerns verändert.
Irre, wie präzise das ist.
Komplett unvorstellbar.
1915 hat Albert Einstein
deren Existenz schon vorhergesagt.
Und es hat über 100 Jahre gedauert,
bis man den finalen Beweis hatte.
Geduld zahlt sich aus.
Beim Higgs-Boson, einem anderen
Elementarteil, auch so.
Das hat man
in den 60er Jahren eingeführt.
Und dann hat es 50 Jahre gedauert,
bis man es nachweisen konnte.
Für beide Entdeckungen
gab es auch Nobelpreise.
Was wäre, wenn nun Mjölnir
Graviton beeinflussen könnte?
Gehen wir davon aus, dass Mjölnir
Graviton ausstoßen könnte.
Das führte dazu, dass sein
Schwerefeld immer größer wird.
Die Anziehungskraft würde dann so
stark, dass es keiner heben kann.
Dieses Prinzip ist auch etwa das,
was wir in der Fiktion sehen.
Hier kann ja nicht mal Halk
den Hammer anheben.
Das hätte aber auch
eine drastische Konsequenz.
Wenn Halk immer stärker wird,
weil er immer wütender wird,
dann würde Mjölnir
auch immer schwerer werden.
Und wenn Halk unendlich wütend ist,
geht Mjölnir durch die Erde durch.
Am Ende wäre ein Schwarzes Loch.
Den Film würde ich gucken.
Wir wollten aber eigentlich klären,
wie wir Mjölnir anheben können.
Das Einfachste wäre es,
würdig zu sein.
Stimmt, easy.
So wie Captain America das macht.
Zumindest in "Age of Ultron"
schafft er es ein wenig.
Und in "Ant Game"
schafft er es dann komplett.
Und er rettet Thor sogar das Leben.
Und, Fun Fact: der Architekt des MCU
sagte in einem Interview,
dass Captain America
schon immer würdig war.
Er hat nur aus Bescheidenheit
und Höflichkeit darauf verzichtet.
Aber es gibt noch weitere Personen,
die den Hammer anheben können.
In den Comics gibt es noch
eine Reihe anderer Leute.
Im neuen "Love and Thunder"
ist es Jane Foster.
*dramatische Musik*
Es ist anscheinend nicht unmöglich,
würdig zu sein.
Wir wissen aber nicht, wer das
entscheidet und was man tun muss.
Es muss noch einen Workaround geben.
Der könnte sich
aus dieser Szene ableiten.
*Sie reden englisch.*
Wenn man Mjölnir
mit einem Lift bewegen könnte,
dann könnte man ihn bewegen,
auch wenn man ihn nicht berührt.
Und dann ist Mjölnir nur das,
was er ist: 19 kg schwer.
Dann bräuchte man nur eine Kraft,
die diese Schwere bewegen kann.
In den Comics sieht man,
dass Magneto sogar den Hammer bewegt.
Aber irgendwie gibt es Regeln dafür.
Iron Man hat einen Handschuh,
kann ihn aber trotzdem nicht anheben.
Auch in dieser Szene reicht der bloße
Kontakt, dass er sich schwer macht.
Das Einfachste wäre,
wenn Thor ihn irgendwo abstellt.
Dann könnte man den Gegenstand
mit Hammer anheben und schleudern.
Da musst du aber gut zielen.
Das wäre sowieso von Vorteil,
den Schurken auch zu treffen.
Eine Sache, über die wir
noch nicht geredet haben:
Was ist, wenn man in
Schwerelosigkeit kämpft, im All?
Diese Idee hat Marvel
auch schon aufgegriffen.
Und zwar in einem Red-Halk-Comic.
Da schafft es Halk, Thor
mit seiner eigenen Waffe zu schlagen.
Aber das wäre im Weltall sinnlos.
Im Weltall gilt ja auch
das 3. Newtonsche Gesetz:
Eine Kraft in die eine Richtung
erzeugt eine gleiche in die andere.
Würde also Halk Thor schlagen,
müssten beide auseinanderfliegen.
Das wäre ein unspannender Kampf.
Aber wenn Mjölnir im Weltall
auf uns zugedriftet kommt,
dann können wir ihn ergreifen.
Aber bestimmt nur
für ein kurzes Selfie.
Denn wir haben ja noch die Gravitone.
Mjölnir ist dann da, wo die
Schwerkraft nicht so krass wirkt,
aber er erzeugt Gravitonen
und ein zunehmendes Schwerefeld.
Wenn Halk danach griffe, entstände
ein riesiges Gravitationsfeld.
Dann würde der Hammer
alles andere anziehen.
Und wahrscheinlich auch die ISS.
Der beste Weg ist daher:
einfach würdig zu sein.
Und dann ist der Hammer nur noch
ein 19 kg schweres Ding.
Und mit ein wenig Training
hat man die gleich Skills wie Thor.
Das hat Spaß gemacht.
Schön, dass du da warst.
Danke.
Die Links zu ihm
packe ich in die Info-Box.
Dein Buch handelt von Gravitation.
- Ja, unter anderem.
Findet ihr auch in der Box.
Schreibt auch,
wie euch die Folge gefallen hat.
Und wie "Love and Thunder"?
Alle Thor-stens sollten sich
jetzt mal zu Wort melden.
Und diese Folge kommentieren.
Und vergesst nicht,
den Kanal zu abonnieren.
Und die Glocke zu drücken.
Bis dahin, ciao.
Hallo, ich bin's, der Dodo.
In der "Jurassic World"-Folge
habt ihr euch mich
in den Kommentaren zurück gewünscht.
Hier bin ich
und präsentiere euch
die Marvel Playlist
von "Science vs. Fiction".
Viel Spaß damit!
UT: MDR 2022